what's the deal with airplane
peanuts I hear this rumor that this
bucket is Rigg and then I go one last
bucket pull let's see what happens and
this monster comes out this is
unbelievable Kil Tony is continuing to
find unreal comedic talent in Austin
Texas straight off of random bucket
poles over the past few months alone
they've added the likes of Cam Patterson
Rick Diaz and most recently the young
sensation Heath cour is to the kill Tony
family but after witnessing Heath win a
Golden Ticket on the very last poll of
the night not everyone is sold on the
fact that all these killer comedians
were randomly pulled out of a bucket
containing hundreds of other names in
fact the story of Heath CES became even
more unbelievable when it was revealed
that he's performed at the mothership
open mics numerous times yet somehow
Tony henchcliffe had never seen met or
heard of Heath before so how is it
possible that someone like Heath cour is
performed in Tony's home Club seven
times without meeting him is there any
real evidence of this show being rigged
and how did Shane Gillis end up
contributing to Heath's historic rise to
answer all these questions and more we
are lucky enough to be joined today by
the one and only kill Tony golden ticket
winner Heath ctis well my first question
for you Heath you did so well on kill
Tony that people now are starting to say
that the bucket might be rigged somehow
is that a compliment for you and do you
have anything to say to those people who
think that the fix was in on your bucket
Pole it very much is a compliment I'm
very flattered that people think that if
it is rigged I don't know about it I've
never met Tony before that Monday I had
a very huge moment me a couple months
ago where I was on a show with him but I
don't think he even knew I was there I
was like third on the lineup he was last
so yeah we never even met but um it was
it was very cool that we met that way
and once you walked on stage you
immediately got to laugh just by saying
the words I feel like
I feel
like did you know that if you ever got
pulled that it was going to be a really
big moment or did it click during your
set like wow I'm doing something very
special right now yeah I I knew it would
take people off guard but I mean I've
seen a lot of people crush and so I
didn't know exactly how it would turn
out you know I wasn't betting on
anything but yeah it turned out way
better than I thought it would be uh
that voice crack completely organic it
helped everything definitely got the
ball rolling but uh yeah I didn't expect
it to turn out the way it would now well
you're two years into comedy now so
meaning that you started at the age of
19 was there any moments where your
appearance or physical appearance might
have got in the way of getting into
shows like an open mic at a bar or
people not letting you even up on stage
yeah I had to do just coffee shops for a
while for like the first year of me
doing standup I lived like an hour away
from the closest open my coffee shop so
I would only do like one open mic a week
and now since I've turned 21 it's just
been completely different and some of
those open mics obviously Kil Tony is a
perfect comedy environment basically
everyone's there to watch they're there
to listen to jokes some of those open
mics can be kind of Rowdy or noisy and a
lot of your funniest moments were like
your facial expressions your control of
the things that you were saying and it
not technically like matching up to your
appearance has it ever been hard at
shows that aren't as perfect for comedy
like kill Tony to get across exactly how
funny you are to just a random unruly
crowd sometimes I've had some bad shows
but usually what it is is people are
just like what the hell is about to
happen and then sometimes they hear the
words that come out of my mouth and they
don't like it so much so if anything
like I can usually get their attention
cuz they're like look at this little boy
about to go on stage but sometimes they
don't like it very much and that's the
problem we saw on Instagram on the
comedy Mothership Instagram you hanging
out with a bunch of comedians at mits
after the show how was that experience
and was there any really cool moments
that you want to share or maybe the
coolest person that you got to meet yeah
I mean that was just absolutely insane I
got to you know have a really special
moment with Tony I had a really special
moment with Shane backstage right before
I got on he was like giving me a pep
talk and that was crazy it was like he
was my guardian angel it was weird but
yeah it was super cool I don't have much
words for it cuz it was just I I never
expected anything like that to happen at
all was it almost like this went so well
that you just wanted to like run out of
the building and be like nope I'm ending
on a high note or were you thrilled to
go back there and hang with everyone or
was that like wow I still got to keep
doing like this nerve-wracking stuff
well um The Hang was super cool extreme
extremely nerve-wracking nerve-wracking
part is going on uh my next time because
you know that was such a big reaction
from everybody so I don't know what's
GNA happen I'm just gonna that obviously
that was my best joke so you know
hopefully people will still like my
other jokes we'll see I think they will
well speaking of that my last question
for you Heath before I'll let you go
you're going to be performing on the
arena show in January Tony called you
maybe the greatest bucket pole of all
time do you feel any pressure climbing
the ranks this fast is there any
negative parts to winning the golden
ticket it's a lot of pressure yeah it's
definitely a lot of pressure um but I'm
just gonna give it my go you know let's
see what happens we also had a chance to
talk with one of the members of the kill
Tony panel who saw this entire thing
unfold live comedian Mike feny speaking
of the mothership though you were just
on an episode of kill Tony and you
witnessed a golden ticket winner right
in front of your eyes kind of a wild
moment what was that like seeing that un
full live when Heath walked out on stage
I mean I think you could see it in our
reactions when you watch it I mean I I
think I'm visibly seen asking like what
the [__] is going on multiple times um
especially because that episode you know
there was a lot of there's a lot of
really funny moments throughout it but
there there weren't a ton of like strong
performances so like you know there
there was some there was some good ones
from the regulars and stuff but like
felt like we were we were having a lot
of fun with the with the guests but then
with the comics that were getting pulled
out of the bucket and then when he came
out man it was just like what the hell
what you know jannis said maybe the
funniest thing that nobody heard cuz he
just said it he didn't say it into the
microphone he just said it to me he
literally just looked at me and was like
what the hell is that thing and it just
was so goddamn funny because no everyone
like people kep were so torn between
like is he lying about his age what's
this dude's story uh you know and then
he was killing obviously gets a standing
ovation kills like Tony said it was like
every question question that you asked
him made you think of 14 other questions
you wanted to ask him so I mean I have a
thousand more the fact that he doesn't
know the exact thing that's going on
with him is to me I I still haven't
slept thinking about it would be my only
mission in light I'd be I'd be up on the
Internet 23 hours a day and then the
other hour would be you know jerking off
or whatever but it's uh it was one of
those moments where all of us sitting on
it like the second it was over we all
looked at each other being like we just
we just witnessed a legendary uh moment
in this Show's history no matter what
happens next with Heath he will always
be a kill Tony Legend especially after
he performs at the kill Tony arena show
this New Year's Eve alongside another
golden ticket winner Rick Diaz who will
be battling Hans Kim for his spot as a
regular on the show if you want to hear
more about the whole situation between
Hans and Rick check out our recap video
right after this guest spots from last
week The Joe Rogan Experience talked
with Elon Musk and David Blaine two
bears one cave was Tom and Colin Quinn
kill Tony this week was with Duncan
Trussell and his puppet Lil hobo Matt
and Shane secret podcast did not have a
guest the honey dude talked with Troy
Bond Joe Gad is a guest on Whiskey
Ginger flagrant did not have a guest
taste buds battled Milky Way vers Nestle
Crunch YH talked with Jimmy Carr Dr Drew
was on first date we might be drunk with
just the boys bertcast featured Ralph
Barbosa Ralph was also on the Blox
podcast and are you garbage what's the
[__] kids in the town you guys have
such great podcast
voice talk real fast you got like this
guy was throwing up the like ww
got I was like oh [__] hit him with the
weather and the traffic real quick keep
it moving baby buddy thanks for coming
in congratulations thank you thanks for
having me you're [__] blowing up man
I do all right this past weekend with
Theo Von spoke with Tucker Carlson the
Tim Dylan show had on Noah tishby Dave
pornoy was the guest on the Adam friedin
show Eli Roth was on tiger belly Ian
fance was on hey bab the shits and gigs
podcast went on Chrissy chaos Lisa
Gilroy was a guest on take your shoes
off Being Ian with Jordan welcomed Mike
feny Lou cats visited stav's World Kyle
dunan was on you know what dude and only
fans welcomed Ari shafir and Steve ranaz
easy as far as new standup specials are
either out right now or coming out soon
Ral Barbosa cabanga and Pete Holmes I'm
not for everyone both premiered recently
on Netflix christalia grow or die came
out for 10 bucks on chia.com TJ Miller
dropped a surprise Halloween special
last week live from the Stanley Hotel
and Mike F's new 20-minute Special A
Night at the comedy Celler is out right
now on YouTube which gives everyone a
super cool look at a night of New York
comedy they do over 80 shows per week
across their four rooms comedy Sellar
village underground Fat Black Pussycat
lounge and the bar as a comic each room
has its own unique feel and requires a
different skill set what kills in one
room May bomb in another and you know
what let me just show you here's all
four rooms in one night and a few
specials in the works right now that are
going to be coming out soon stavos haas'
next special fat Rascal is set to come
out on Netflix December 5th also coming
to Netflix soon will be Matt R natural
selection premiering November 15th and
the day before that a new special by
Trevor Wallace will be added to Amazon
Prime titled Tera dactyl also not
technically a standup special but Taylor
Tolson is taking over The Late Night
time slot after coar on CBS as host of
her new show after midnight which is big
news that's had people talking all week
long another new comedy project coming
out very soon civic duty which is a
short film by Sam ruof starring Joe list
and Tommy Pope and will be premiering
this week on November 9th at the New
York Festival other than that Andrew
Schultz just announced he will be
performing at Madison Square Garden when
his tour hits New York which we will be
sure to cover more in depth once that
happens and lastly anyone watching this
video in the Tampa Bay and St Pete
region of the world a very funny
comedian Trevor glasman is headlining
the sunshine City Comedy Club November
12th please consider subscribing to the
channel right now if you want to stay in
the comedy Loop thank you so much for
watching this video and if you're
interested in claiming your free joke
World stickers check out the links in
the description below
joke
world that's did it J
world and it world is W
rld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out